apple is going to revolutionize the
tablet market in such a strong way that
i don't think that samsung will have a
chance since the ipad pro has the m1
chip it makes total sense for the next
one to have the m2 chip should either be
revealed in october or november it's
gonna feature a new design with wireless
charging support and it's also getting
reverse wireless charging as well it's
gonna destroy the upcoming samsung
galaxy tab s8 on so many levels that it
won't even be funny apple will bring all
the new features from the ipad mini 6 to
the upcoming air 5 which is probably
going to be a fair match to samsung's
flagship tab s8 the design is going to
remain unchanged with the dual camera
system from the ipad pro it's going to
arrive sometime in the spring for the
past three years apple has released
their budget ipad in september i can
expect apple to do that again with a new
design with a larger display but even
without a full redesign it's a better
buy than any tablet that samsung has to
offer on the lower end